[Music]
[ __ ] I don't know how to use this thing
did I look to you to destroy your oh
crap
but yeah thank you the GI for this
amazing gift this is a Mavic air I have
no idea how to fly it but it's okay I
got Matthew here so Matthew come here
why don't you teach me how to fly this
oh no no okay this is I'll just shut the
camera my 24th year was the year of
growth and it all started on March 12
2017
I spent my 24th birthday sleeping on the
train in Korea after clubbing I then
moved to New York and started my first
full-time job at BuzzFeed as a data
scientist I made my first appearance in
a BuzzFeed video that 15 minutes of fame
felt pretty good and I appeared in more
BuzzFeed videos I then moved to Bay Area
and started my job at Facebook as a data
scientist working for the video creator
team I dressed up as my bitmoji for
Halloween and then I met my Yuko and did
a collab prefer and then finally I
started the startup series and I forced
all my co-workers to be in them
and Here I am today blessed with an
amazing team at work but most
importantly I'm blessed a few guys who
supported me along the way and thank you
for making this community amazing but it
wasn't always that easy it wasn't all
smooth sailing
I actually faced a lot of failures
before realizing that what I really
needed was to learn to accept myself
with what I have
I tried starting a startup and fell six
times during college I applied to
product management positions at Facebook
and Google with no offers I worked for a
whole year making videos on YouTube and
Facebook only to gain 200 subscribers at
the end but I continued to pursue those
goals because setbacks are hard but
they're the ones that will teach you the
most about yourself what you're capable
and what you really want and don't
forget that the things that are worth
achieving will never be easy so say yes
to the grind because I know that one day
somewhere are someone will recognize
your effort and you'll be rewarded
but remember before everything else
before you do sight of what's important
you have to step back and remember who
are there for you and who made sure as
possible
[Music]
but thank you for all of you guys who
came along the way but I'm just getting
started my goal this year is to cherish
everything you guys have given to me and
I will give it back to you guys
however I can because I owe it to you
guys so thank you so much and I'll see
you soon very soon
[Music]
you